we're joined now by dr ashish jha he's
dean of brown university's school of
public health
good morning to you dr zha you've just
heard morea's report that even eligible
people are having a hard time
getting the vaccine that's so badly
needed so what needs to be done to turn
this around
yeah it's a good morning gail thanks for
having me on a couple of things first of
all obviously we just need more vaccine
doses and that's coming
uh it's still frustrating to have to
wait
um but the second is the complexity has
to be made a lot more simple i don't
understand why
people have to get up early in the
morning and be on the computer all day
we should be able to come up with much
much simpler systems when you look at
states that are doing a great job
they've made it really simple and easy
for people to get vaccinated
i think all states should be following
that rule i know everybody agrees with
you this should not be this hard in 2021
let's talk about the new direction from
the cdc yesterday that
to mask or better than one you're more
effectively covered a do you agree with
that recommendation and
b how in the world are we going to get
people to wear too when people are
arguing about wearing one
i know right so two things i mean first
of all
i do agree with that recommendation i've
been i've been that's what i've been
doing uh for probably about a month or
so and it's nice to see cdc come out
with data on that the point i i think
that's really important for people is
you don't need to wear two masks at all
times
at all when you're out and about in the
public if you're not around
in crowds uh any mask one mask is
totally fine
the two mass situation is really for
high risk things so when you're
if you're gonna be in a grocery store
for any extended period of time if
you're gonna be indoors with a lot of
people
uh who are not part of your household
for any extended period of time you
start with that surgical mask you just
put a cloth mask on top of it you get a
much better fit
you get better filtration it is just
much much safer
you should hold those for high risk
situations you said you started wearing
two masks
a month ago why did you start doing that
and didn't tell us about that
i didn't know you were doing that doctor
i'm thinking maybe i should have been
wearing
what made you start doing it a month ago
yeah yeah i
i don't mean to hold out on you gail and
the reason i started doing it is because
of these variants and especially the uk
variant
which is so much more contagious and as
soon as i knew it was here and it was
starting to take off
i started changing some of my practices
okay there are other alternatives as
well you can get a high quality mask but
i do think it's important to be wearing
good mats right now yeah let's talk
about those variants do you think that
they're
now outpacing the vaccines
that's what i'm worried about and i
think you know those variants especially
the uk variant
is here is probably in every state in
the country uh
it's doubling the numbers are doubling
every 10 days of that and by mid-march
it'll to late march it'll be everywhere
that's our target we've got to get
high-risk people vaccinated by then
some states will do it i'm worried that
other states won't let's talk about the
opening of schools you know the biden
administration said the other day
that they're now going to focus on
mitigation efforts like wearing a mask
as opposed to focusing on
vaccinating the teachers what do you
think of that plan
i think that's exactly right i think we
have very good evidence now that if you
do mitigation if you get people to wear
mass if you make sure there's reasonable
ventilation
if you can do a little testing in
schools all of that makes schools very
safe for
kids and teachers again look if we had
plenty of vaccines it'd be great to
vaccinate the teachers but i don't think
that's an essential feature of getting
kids back to school all right dr john
it's always good to have you here thank
you so much